仔姐姐你好，
好呀，
你遇到啥事儿了？
我有好几个问题，
我首先啊，
我是独生女，
然后我想问一下，
因为是我爸妈名下有一套房子嘛，
不是都说继承房产就是父母卖给孩子，
这样是最便宜的嘛，
那假如我婚后做这套手续，
是不是推变成夫妻共同财产，
如果你以买卖的方式的话，
确实有这方面的风险，
因为你以买卖的方式啊，
从法律关系上来说的话，
就是你从父母那儿买一个东西，
父母和子女之间除了有父母的关系，
父母子女的关系，
你们还是两个平等的主体，
可以发生买卖关系。
如果你以买卖的方式从父母那里拿到一套房的话，
你买回来的这个东西那就是夫妻共同的财产，
从法律上逻辑上就是这样子，
如果是以继承的方式到手，
然后如果我把这套房子卖掉再买，
如果也是发生在婚后再买一套房子，
是不是也是夫妻共同同财产，
这样子如果以继承的方式的话，
就分为两种情况，
一种情况是你的父母立下了遗嘱，
然后这个房子归你一个人单独所有来继承，
跟你的配偶没有关系，
白纸黑字的写明白，
那么你继承得到的这个房产是属于你一个人的。
另一种情况，
你的父母没有立下遗嘱，
如果他们去世了，
黑不提白不提，
然后你通过合法的程序。
把这个房子过户到你名下，
你完成这个继承的话，
得到这个房产是夫妻共同的财产，
这两种不同的情形，
我们以第一种就是说如果父母有遗嘱，
然后你继承得到这个房产还属于你的个人财产的情况下，
如果你要卖这套房，
那么你就要单独开一张卡，
那张卡不要跟你婚内的财产，
那些存款不要混在一起放，
你单独用那张卡来收你爸爸妈妈遗留下来这套房产所卖，
然后得到的这个房产的话，
那么这个房款还是你的个人财产，
如果你将就这个房款全款去买一套房，
还登记在你的名下，
注意啊，
包括税费，
包括各种各样的中介费，
包括什么钱都是用这个钱出，
那么你全款去买一套房，
还登记在你的名下的话，
这个房还是你的个人财产，
也就是说我能够用证据去从头到尾的说明我婚后啊，
买的这套房就是我爹妈那套房变过来的，
那他还是你的，
理解这个逻辑吗？
嗯，
理解了，
然后我就被我妈头疼死了，
她不是催我婚嘛，
然后我就说要催，
我问，
我说就是假如我将来要结婚，
我说未雨绸缪一下，
我说你们遗嘱得提前写好，
然后他就骂我，
咒他，
他如果说你结婚之前他直接给你办过户不就得了吗？
办过户又觉得不太好，
他们就觉得还不太。
好，
这样子这事儿的话就是如果他们愿意将来眼睁睁的看着他们那套房被将来那个对你不好的男人，
且打你且背叛你的男人分走一半的资产，
很多老年人就算不明白这个账，
就是现在你觉得立遗嘱这个事儿好像是咒你，
但如果说你不立遗嘱的话，
那么将来有可能出现一个人，
她不光打你的女儿，
欺负你的女儿，
背叛你的女儿，
她还能分走我也，
我也这么说，
然后他说没有，
这种事都是个例而已，
他俩去年就有一个案例，
分走了差不多几千万呢，
就是女方的父母去世了之后留下来的财产，
价值2个多亿，
然后后来男方分走了几千万，
但上我家也没什么钱，
然后这就是道我第二个问题就是你上次停播之前我就想连你了，
因为我想问你我能不能和我男朋友结婚，
但是在你停播的时候，
我已经分手分掉了，
然后他就在闹我，
他还等着我12月订婚，
明年就结婚，
催的我烦死了，
然后就因为分手的时候就是有一些情况，
我我觉得心里不太舒服，
因为我从小到大第一次谈恋爱，
所以想让你分析一下，
就是我和我男朋友是相亲认识的，
我们从出事的时候就是让我感到心里膈应的时候，
就是我们从认识才两个多。
月，
因为我们是在老家那个小县城，
我我们两个都是国企，
老家小县城的国企，
然后小地方就是这种催婚催的紧，
然后他又大我4岁，
就是我们头几个月，
我觉得他人还挺好的，
就是虽然就是我们爱好很不同，
但是他虽然不理解，
但是也尊重我了，
我觉得好像他看起来人品还行，
然后就是出事那天正好是我生日，
从见面那天开始算，
但我生日才两个多月，
还不是正式交往两个多月，
他就想强留我在他家过夜，
把我吓死了。
后面我们虽然长谈了一次，
就是话都说开了，
说以后就是你不舒服就说，
我不舒服就说，
然后他也认可了，
但是他总是在说，
就是我不和他接受亲密关系，
就是不太喜欢他的样子，
然后我前段时间就和他分手了嘛，
我提分手之后，
然后他就追到我家楼下来，
然后一副也不是要死要活，
就是搞得特情深的那种，
我们又不是交往了10年的男女朋友，
然后搞得特别煽情，
因为我那个时候正好在准备考公，
然后我跟他提前说过，
我考完试以后我们再常谈这件事情，
两三天后考完试后，
然后我再和他谈这个事情，
他就突然变非常冷。
我然后就哦了一句，
然后我们这个手应该算是彻底分掉了吧，
第一次谈恋爱我也不懂，
是我确实没给他什么足够的关心还是什么，
还是他确实不太对劲呢？
我这是心心里实在是不得劲，
所以想问问你，
你今年是多大了？
姑娘，
我是二十八九的感，
你以前高中大学工作了之后就从来没有谈过恋爱，
是不是对我只能这么说啊，
就是男生他跟你谈恋爱两个月，
他想要留你在他家里过夜，
这件事情几乎可以说是比较正常的一种现象，
他想留你过夜是正常现象，
但他强留你过夜就是不对的。
我这么跟你讲吧，
男生基本上只要跟女的相亲啊，
谈恋爱啊，
约会啊，
看电影啊，
吃饭啊，
他无时无刻在脑子里面都在构想我怎么才能亲到他，
我怎么才能拉到他的手，
哪一个契机比较合适？
我怎么才能够拿下他？
我直播间也有男同学，
男同学在我直播间是吧？
可以跟萌菲姐反馈一下我说的对还是不对？
男生她只要跟一个女生，
她要去约会吧，
就是一起吃饭，
一起看电影，
一起散步，
一起出去玩儿啊，
干嘛干嘛的，
她无时无刻在脑子里面都在想，
我什么时机拉他的手合适，
我什么时时机亲他一口合适，
我什么情况下才能够跟他单独相处，
把他拿下，
就是男生有这个想法是很正常的，
他想要留你在他家里过夜这件事儿是很正常的。
然后后面就是我们第一次常谈。
那次我就问他嘛，
我说你那天强留我，
是想和我做到底吗？
他说他只是想试探我，
但是我那天晚上是真的被他吓怕了，
因为是在他家里，
不是在外面，
然后在他家里他给我过了一个生日嘛，
可能是我都适合谈恋爱吧，
我觉得真的是没有办法，
他就希望就是这种特别全身心黏在一起，
这种我觉得受不了，
我想要有一点自己的空间，
这样子你为从小到大独冠了嘛，
都是一个人过来的，
那你就是坦率的说，
你可能并不是很喜欢她是吧，
你并不是很接纳她，
我再跟你们讲一个好不好，
所有的单身的，
没有谈过恋爱的，
或者没有过那方面经验的女孩子，
你都给我记牢了，
在男人的世界里面，
你答应去他家，
就约等于答应要跟睡觉，
你答应跟他去开，
就一定是等于要答应跟他睡觉，
你们要懂这样的社会规则，
要懂这样的恋爱规则，
你以为你答应去他家过个生日，
就是简简单单的过个生日，
在男人的世界里面，
你只要答应去他家跟他在封闭的一个环境下，
他就默认为你要答应跟他较了，
理解了吗？
主要是我事后跟我闺蜜说这件事情嘛，
我说他们是不是想就是生米煮成熟饭，
然后把你给绑架了，
讲样那倒未必，
人家也未必想跟你结婚啊，
姑娘，
对不起啊，
这龙菲姐，
你把我当成一个。
是邻居家的姐姐，
咱俩就像我当时就是，
确实我们俩已经谈到结婚这件事，
因为你知道小地方，
这个地方真的好怪，
相亲哦，
一下就结了，
这样子我跟你讲，
如果他都还没有跟你有那种亲密的关系的时候，
他根本压根儿就不会想结婚那档子事儿，
他还不知道你俩合不合适呢，
他还不知道他跟你在一起是什么感觉呢，
他还不知道他爱不爱你呢，
我也觉得奇怪，
我们还没交往上的时候，
她就说她爱我，
然后刚交往就让我叫她老公，
我觉得真的好奇怪，
我说不出口啊，
好羞耻，
姑娘，
你这个情况啊，
你听了媒体了，
你至少谈了两三个才考虑结婚的事儿啊，
你太没有经验了，
太没有经验的女孩子，
他跟他谈过，
不是她谈过，
是她有经验，
你没有经验啊，
你太没有经验了的女孩子的话，
你就太容易把这个事儿当回事儿，
你就太容易把对方当回事儿，
你就太容易胡思乱想，
你就太容易把对方的一句话琢磨半天，
其实有谈恋爱这个事情也跟那个打预防针似的，
你打疫苗似的，
你知道吗？
你需要去免疫很多东西，
如果你真的上来从来没谈过恋爱，
上来谈一个去结婚，
去生孩子，
你会把她说的每一句话当回事儿，
你会很累的好不好？
如果说这个男朋友已经分手了，
不要去想了，
你就听龙飞姐的啊，
保证对方身体健康，
比如双方。
多去抽血验一下有没有病，
有没有性理传播疾病，
保证双方身体健康，
保证做好孕，
孕妇湿的情况下的话，
一定在结婚之前最起码谈个两三个好，
我可能还是真的不适合，
我对你有心理障碍，
因为他那天晚上那个行为不知道为什么让我PDS地震了，
因为之前就是诶骚扰过，
就那个封闭的空间，
让我就是有点害怕，
然后我就跟我妈说我不想结婚，
然后她就又哭了又了，
那我认真跟你聊一下这个事情啊，
老粉丝都知道龙佩姐小的时候也被背过，
我为啥要跟你聊这个事情呢？
啊，
我是这么看待这个问题的，
如果我现在还沉浸在一个受害者的一个角色里面的话，
相当于那个人对我的伤害不是停留在我几岁的时候，
那个人对我的伤害就持续到我了40年，
但如果说现在我不把他当回事儿，
我觉得他不影响我正常的恋爱，
正常的结婚，
不影响我对男人的信任，
不影响我对男人的审美，
不影响我对夫妻生活的享受，
那么她对我造成的伤害就约等于不存在了。
大家能理解龙月姐想讲这个逻辑吗？
所以曾经被伤害的女孩子，
一定要拿这一套逻辑来说服我自己，
我一定要让自己健康起来，
不会因为一个为难，
不会因为一个坏人，
她做的这样一个龌龊的事情，
让我对所有男人都产生怀疑，
对所有男人都产生。
抗拒，
那就说明他对我的伤害持续了这么多年，
持续到今天还对我有伤害。
但如果我跳出那个受害者的圈子，
我正常的用客观的视角去看待男人，
我也依然愿意相信男人依然愿意享受亲密关系，
那么他对我就没有造成实质性的伤害。
我不允许那个伤害我的人他获胜，
如果我40年我都不谈恋爱，
我都对男人怀疑，
我不去享受那么美好的亲密关系的话，
就相当于他获胜了，
我失败了，
我不允许这样的结果存在，
到最后一定是我要获胜，
怎么才能获胜呢？
不是当我已经不把他伤害我这件事儿当成什么鸟事儿的时候，
我就获胜了，
那我是不是应该去看一下心理医生，
做梦梦就想起这件事情啊，
可以了，
可以，
我们，
呃，
看心理医生也好，
就是多跟姐妹们聊聊天也好，
我明确告诉你啊，
像在我的印象当中，
女孩子从小长大的过程当中，
比如说被因骚扰有点这个基本上能够占到很大的比重，
可能有百分之七八十的女孩子都遭遇过，
就这意思啊，
就是我一定要把自己从那个受害者的角色里面把它拔出来，
我要成为那个战胜了那个龌龊的男人的一个女人，
我怎么战胜她，
对他已经对我做的那些事情，
对我已经不造成任何的伤害了，
I don't care,
就是我已经不在乎这件事情了I。
Care这件事情了，
那我就战胜了他，
我觉得我一直忘不掉，
就是因为是好后悔，
当时没有报警，
就每次想这件事情都在后悔，
因为小地方嘛，
就怕我爸妈被他找，
现在把自己当成一个重生的重生的大女主，
现在你们不都流行看那个短剧嘛，
看重生大女主短剧吗？
一定要把自己当成一个重生的大女主来看待，
如果可以的话，
咱们可以多去找一些有同样经历的姐妹们多聊聊天，
或者找心理咨询师多聊聊天，
我相信你一定要战胜那个曾经欺负你的人，
也战胜自己，
不要一直沉浸在受害者那个角色里面，
就是我永远是我的人生的第一种导演，
我可以决定我想演什么角色，
如果我想演一个幸福的角色，
那我就给自己设定一个幸福的角色，
好，
谢谢你，
美姐。